dégager au pied on se rangera aaa
[Musique]
le
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les faits
[Musique]
il
nous
[Musique]
je
et voilà c'est déjà la fin de la vidéo
j'espère en tout cas qu'elle vous aura
plu parce qu'on m'a on a passé beaucoup
de temps déguisé en bio ab je devrais je
tiens vraiment à remercier florent et
jérémy qui m'ont vraiment aidé à faire
cette vidéo en tout cas sachez qu
atteindre les 100 mille abonnés c'est un
peu un rêve qui se réalise c'est quand
même un chiffre vraiment énorme
on va pas se mentir un cent mille
abonnés c'est quelque chose de
gigantesque et est donc ouais donc voilà
je voulais vraiment encore tous et tous
vous remercier j'espère au moins que
cette vidéo aura été à la hauteur de vos
espérances
au niveau des musiques je vais
maintenant à pêcher le type de chacune
des musiques maintenant puisque je sais
qu'il va pas mal qu'ils voudront
connaître les noms et sinon dans la
description je mettrais minutes une
annotation aussi je mettrais un lien
vers la vidéo en coupant l'intro c'est à
dire vous aurez juste le mix des
musiques donc comme la dans la vidéo
avec bacon dans son but donc l2 sera en
ont répertorié en gros vous aurez juste
à cliquer sur le bouton replay pour vous
retaper le mix des musiques son intro et
puis voilà en tout cas sachez que c'est
vraiment quelque chose d'énorme que je
suis vraiment super content de deux là
où j'en suis vraiment et je suis content
de vous comme de moi voilà je suis je
suis vraiment content et puis n'oubliez
pas de laisser un petit j'aime sur la
vidéo si elle vous a plu parce qu'on n'y
a vraiment passé beaucoup de temps
que ce soit au tournage comme montage
voilà encore merci tout le monde
à bientôt by me
[Musique]
alors je cherche juste à faire un petit
bonus donc vous pourrez voir sur
diverses séquences qui n'a pas mal de
gens en arrière-plan qui nous regardent
ou qui font les cons et aussi sur la
toute dernière séquence si vous regardez
bien je vais la repasser au ralenti
juste là la fille dans la voiture était
vraiment mignonne et si vous regardez
bien je me prends la branche voilà donc
c'était juste un petit bonus comme ça
ciao